With an estimated 2 million narcotics smuggled into the United States each day, and ⅓ students
Universities like Stanford say they have tried it, MDMA or "Molly" has become
The most popular drug. But what exactly is it? How does it affect your body?
Scientifically known as 3,4-methylene-deoxy-methylamine "ecstasy", is usually taken in the form of pills and hypothetical
To be composed of a pure chemical. Ecstasy on the other hand, is an MDMA
It has been chemically modified with the addition of other substances such as amphetamine and caffeine.
In its pure form MDMA affects neurotransmitters in the brain. Neurons are chemicals
In your body that transmits messages, while also controlling other things such as reflexes, and emotions
And memory. In particular, the neurotransmitter labeled serotonin controls appetite, sleep
Memory and learning in this mood. When there is something really great happening in your life
For example, when you fall in love, there is an increase in the secretion of serotonin from the neurons
Which eventually stimulates your body and makes you feel happy. And it happens
Also when you take adequate amounts of MDMA, these same cells are stimulated to excrete
Massive amounts of serotonin, along with other neurotransmitters such as dopamine
Noraphenfarin leads to the release of more electrochemicals in the brain. This change creates
Intense experience of happiness, social feeling, increased empathy and inability to sleep,
Making it one of the most popular drugs used in concerts
These feelings usually last about 3-8 hours, when the brain cells are normal
To absorb serotonin, and chemically destroy it, but because MDMA excretes a lot of
Serotonin, also destroys the body more than usual. This means when your brain works
Due to its nature, there are fewer serotonin available to bind to your receptors
Which make you feel comfortable with normal events. This can also lead to vertigo
In addition to side effects such as negative mood, depression, irritability and feeling
Very tired
Regardless of the adverse effects, studies have shown that MDMA can be used as a potential treatment for PTSD
And anxiety. Patients with PTSD "post-traumatic disorder" generally have a lack of brain connections
Between the amygdala and the hippocampus (two regions of the brain), but the analysis of MRI showed that MDMA was actually active
Increases communication in these areas. However, this treatment is still somewhat controversial
Studies on mice and monkeys have shown that even small amounts of MDMA are not only destroyed
The endings of brain cells that are involved in the release of serotonin, but potentially also be
Cause permanent damage to the brain
If you have not seen it before, we have a new video about the taste of taste
We suffer with taste challenges to show you how to eat complex food!
Click on the screen or use the link in the Description box
Subscribe to more weekly videos